We're asked to
add 0.822 to 5.65.
So let me rewrite this.
And when I rewrite it, I
want to line up the decimals
so that we add the right
place to the right place.
And so we could write
either number first,
although I like to write
the larger number first.
So let's write 5.65.
And remember, the
important thing
is that we line up
the decimal points.
So if we write 0.822-- so
we line up the decimal.
Let me line up
the decimal first.
So I'll write the decimal
right below the other decimal.
And it is 0.822.
And now we are ready to add.
So let's see what's
going on here.
So I like to start in
the smallest place.
That way, the carrying
works out well.
So you might say, wait,
I need to add this 2
thousandths to something.
I don't see anything up here.
Well, you could say there's just
a 0 thousandths right up here.
Then it makes it very clear.
Well, 0 thousandths
plus 2 thousandths
is going to be 2 thousandths.
5 hundredths plus 2
hundredths is 7 hundredths.
6 tenths plus 8
tenths is 14 tenths.
Well, 14 tenths is the same
thing as 4 tenths and 1 one.
Another way of thinking about
it is you're carrying the 1.
But really, what you're saying
is, look, this is 14 tenths.
I could write it as 4 tenths
and a 1, or a ones place, a 1
in a ones place.
Then you have 1 plus 5 is 6.
And of course, you cannot
forget the decimal.
The decimal goes right there.
And this is 6.472.